hi this is one of those videos one of
those videos where I just plop you down
on something and try to make sense of it
I just wanted to give you guys some
updates there's been so many rumors
going around on the internet the Justine
did you quit YouTube
Justine are you pregnant Justine are you
actually not really alive as your life
expired no I haven't and as proof of
life March 13th at 5:57 p.m. I'm here
I'm alive all as well I've got a list of
things that I wanted to talk to you guys
about because there's been so much stuff
going on and I haven't had any time to
actually sit down and seriously have a
real conversation with you guys if
you've been following me on Instagram or
snapchat or Twitter then you probably
know what I've been up to I've been
doing this crazy tour with call of duty
every year they do this thing called
Call of Duty Championships it's at the
end of March this year and it's a
million dollar tournament so we decided
to go all around the world to all of
like the regional competitions and
interview players and do all kinds of
stuff so it's been so much fun aside
from that there's been a ton of things
going on I think in 2015 in general some
of you guys probably know some of you
don't I think that you guys can probably
discuss all of those things for those of
you that may be in the know in the
comments below so have a fun time doing
that um some of you guys are just really
you guys just really know everything
in other news some of you guys actually
don't even know that I've been working
on a book for the past year and a half
probably been working on it my entire
life actually because it's sort of about
my life and I'm really excited because I
think Monday we might have some really
big news for you but here's the problem
I still don't have a title yet for the
book and I've got a few ideas but I
really have been trying to make this
sort of an interactive process even
though some of you guys didn't even know
this was all going on so I want to hear
your suggestions as far as a book title
and I'm hoping that some of you guys
will come up with the idea that I have
in my head of what I think I want to
call it but I basically need to have
this title buy it last week so leave me
some comments about what you think that
I should have the title of this book be
and it's kind of crazy because it's
going to be
out so soon it's almost finished and
it's kind of crazy going back and just
reading it and and I just hope that you
guys will read it and and just it to the
last page feel inspired and go and take
on the world
that's my hope if you want to preorder
it I'll put a link in the description
I'll have all kinds of more information
regarding that said book next week but
I'm having an LA meet up tomorrow and I
am so excited about it it's going to be
a Best Buy I've done a bunch of events
with Best Buy and Intel before but this
one's gonna be really fun because
tomorrow is international drone day or
today depending upon when you're
watching this video and it's going to be
the best buy in torrance and we're going
to be doing like all kinds of fun demos
we're gonna have like this la drone
production company team come out and
they're gonna do all kinds of demos and
I'm hosting it and I get to meet you
guys and I'm not sure how many Anne's I
just said so that's from 12 o'clock to 2
and then I'm heading to South by
Southwest in Austin Texas where I'm
hoping to see some more of you guys my
friend Lizzie is by far one of the most
inspirational and amazing people that I
have ever met and she has been putting
so much of her just efforts into
creating this documentary that she's
been working on for the past year and
it's finally premiering also tomorrow
which i'm so sad i have to miss because
i already was planning this BestBuy
event so it is tomorrow it's premiering
in Austin I'll put all of the info also
in the description and if any of you
guys happened to be there please go
check it out there's going to be so many
more screenings next week I'll be at the
one on Monday we're also doing a panel
on Sunday again all the infos and
description I don't want to miss say
anything and get you guys confused but
if you guys are in Texas and you're able
to make it to her premiere to her
screening to our panel I'm excited
because we're both sort of gonna be
interviewing each other and she's so
awesome like I'm kind of speechless and
actually today is her birthday and I
wish I was there to give her a big hug
on her birthday um she's amazing
absolutely just by far the most amazing
person ever I love the film it's so good
and I'm just so honored to be able to
call her a friend and now I'm gonna cry
I'm all emotional I'm also getting over
a cold
so just hot mess what else is on my list
okay book title Lizzy caught champs best
by Meetup my gaming channel I would like
to just apologize because I've honestly
have just not had time to to play games
I've been playing a lot of DS stuff and
I just thought Mario Party and I wanted
to be able to try to post some stuff
before I leave but I kinda have to
finish this book like right now so
that's on the to-do list also I know a
lot of you guys want some cooking videos
I have two of them that I have not been
able to post one was a collab of Josh
Sundquist and Josh I'm so sorry I'm by
far the worst person ever because we
filmed this like last month and I'm not
done editing it yet anyway that's really
all I've got to say ah that's not sure
about so much more to say today oh my
god I lost my Nintendo DS freaked out
you could potentially call it a midlife
crisis I thought that I lost my Nintendo
- yes that had years and years and years
of Streep has dad on it which I did
thankfully have backed up to my computer
but still I left it on the plane this oh
my god I can't even tell you this
morning I woke up I was like you know
what I didn't have my Nintendo DS
yesterday and usually I mean I check
everywhere that I go for Street passes
and I had lunch with Jenna
my sister yesterday and I was like did
you get StreetPass for me yesterday
lunch except maybe I left it at lunch
she said no she did it and that's what I
knew I left it on the Virgin America
flight from back from Chicago yesterday
I am can't even believe it couldn't
believe it because I always do a roll
call before I get off the plane or
before I do anything like okay do you
have your phone that's usually number
one number two do you have your camera
yes number three yes and they're all
kind of like on the same level of
priority but that's usually the order
that I have my things stacked hidden do
roll call who's so tired so sick I left
it on the plane
so I had a moment of weakness and I
started tweeting Virgin America and
thankfully they had my IDs they had it I
went and traffic was so
la today it took me three and a half
hours round-trip from my house to the
airport and back I was like this is
ridiculous I love you Los Angeles but
holy moly you guys are you guys were
messed up um I just looked up and I
thought I didn't hit record I was like
come on no why you gotta be so rude why
you gotta be so rude
don't you know I'm recordin to that a
lot more fun things coming up and I'm so
excited to be able to get to do a book
tour that's probably what I'm most
looking forward to this year is getting
to meet you guys because I wasn't able
to make it to playlist and meeting you
guys honestly gives me the inspiration
to keep making YouTube videos and to
keep making content because when you're
just sitting here talking to a camera
you don't actually get to see people I
don't see you I don't get the full
effective of knowing that there's real
people watching it so when I get to meet
you guys and see you and hear your
stories of either how you found my
videos or I don't know just how much you
enjoy the Internet and I don't know I'm
not really sure I'm saying I'm just
saying I love you you guys are my
inspiration to keep doing what I'm doing
and this book is really for you it's
just I just hope that you really like it
and I'm very excited for you to see the
cover photo that we decided to go with
so I'm slightly embarrassed but like I'm
real pumped up about it
oh my gosh okay I'm gonna go because I I
don't know
I gotta edit this video and go to bed so
I can see you guys tomorrow um that's it
I love you I'm not pregnant
I'm I'm what else what did I say I'm not
quitting YouTube I don't even remember
what you guys all the rumors have been
um that's it so yeah I'll see you guys
later I love you and I hope to see you
tomorrow or at South by or wherever else
we'll see you am I